Everyone goes through a period of figuring out who they're attracted to, and
who is attracted to them. Sexual identity involves figuring out who we are
sexually, what we like and don't like, and who we're attracted to. Recent
surveys of American teens have reported that around 88% of teenagers describe
themselves as predominantly heterosexual. About 1 to 2%of teens describe
themselves as predominantly homosexual or bisexual. And about 10% of teens
describe themselves as being confused about their sexual orientation. Now, the
formation of your identity also revolves around experimenting and trying other
adult type behaviors, such as drinking alcohol or doing drugs. As the
psychologist, Erik Erikson put it, being a teen involves forming our identity
in at least three main areas. Sexual, Ideological and occupational. We form our
identity through our relationships, that's the sexual part. Our political and
religious beliefs, that's the ideological part. And through career choices,
that's the occupational part. To put it simply, being a teenager means trying
to figure out who we like, what we believe, and what career is best suited for
us.